no two of us are exactly alike and no
one birth control method is just right
for everyone
there are several family planning
methods that work very well
and some that don't work very well at
all
[Music]
[Applause]
you can get help in choosing a birth
control method that is safe reliable
inexpensive and just right for you
[Music]
want time to become yourself before you
become a parent
[Music]
an effective birth control method will
give you that time
[Music]
people all of us right now challenged by
uncontrolled population growth
all of man's efforts to raise living
standards to give every baby a chance
for a useful life are endangered to meet
the challenge the world needs family
planning through planned parenthood
world population the organization
extending vital birth control services
in america and overseas
give every baby a chance to be a wanted
child planned parenthood needs your
support give generously
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
life does repeat itself
but some things change
today more people can plan their
families
they choose to make life better
for themselves
and their children
for this freedom to choose
support planned parenthood
family planning means freedom to choose
support planned parenthood
[Music]
good morning planned parenthood
yes this is the birth control agency
will this be your first visit
would you like a morning or evening
appointment
will this wednesday at nine be
convenient
yes just tell the lady at the front desk
your name
yes you can bring your children
[Music]
no you shouldn't have to wait too long
first you'll be interviewed by member of
our staff
what method that'll be up to you and the
doctor
yes of course you'll see the doctor
there is no set fee the cost depends
upon family income
yes our records are confidential
yes this wednesday morning at 9. do you
want help in planning your family
call 726-5134
you don't have to plan a family
[Applause]
it's just that people who do are happier
[Music]
so are their children
[Music]
[Applause]
for happier families
support planned parenthood
between me lola filana and the young
ladies of the country okay
because a million teenage girls got
pregnant last year and most of them
didn't mean to they just didn't have
enough knowledge or self-respect to use
some kind of birth control listen to
lola treat yourself like the special
person that you are if you're going to
have sex protect yourself and if you're
not ready to handle sex slow down you'll
keep make a life for yourself before you
make another life a message from the u.s
public health service and your local
family planning agency
no tommy you can't come over
because my mom and dad aren't home
[Music]
i'd like to see you too but you can't
come over
i do you know i care about you but that
doesn't mean that
i don't care what everyone else is doing
i don't have to give you a reason it's
just my decision okay
if it's getting harder to say no
talk it over with your parents and write
us for saying no
[Music]
the quality of life in america is
threatened by overpopulation
voluntary family planning can slow
population
he's growth at you get out in the street
thing called
maryland
at the time i had my first little boy
when i was only 15 years old 11 months
later i had a little girl 10 and a half
months later had another little girl
left